in Myanmar's north for more than 50
years Shan State has been the
battleground for armed Earth Nick groups
fighting the country's army for more
autonomy during a recent army offensive
military helicopters were seen opening
fire in civilian areas in a township of
northern Shan State the sound of
helicopters and allow explosions were
terrifying it doesn't matter if they
were in town or nearby the sound was
very frightening for the children just
this month an Amnesty International
report accused the military of
committing war crimes against civilians
in northern Shan State the report also
said that armed ethnic groups used
abusive tactics as they fight the army
and among themselves as they battle for
control in shan state an area rich in
minerals and where much of the world's
illegal opium and heroin is produced
civilians fleeing the recent fighting
gathered at a Buddhist temple seen as a
safe haven most of them are part of the
dong hill tribe for generations they
have cultivated tea as their main source
of income got my ID and because they
have been fighting like this we can't go
and pick the tea this causes a big
problem if the tea ever ripens and
nobody will want to buy it and that's
caused economic problem mr. northern
Shan State is one of Myanmar's least
developed regions so if the fighting
continues there's little hope that this
situation will improve for the people
here an example of the failure of a
nationwide ceasefire agreement signed
four years ago but it could also mean
political difficulties for leader Aung
song su Chi once she starts campaigning
for next year's election Scott Heidler
al Jazeera